[Music]
now let's go
live to jessie spano jesse
good morning i'm here with principal
richard belding
who is this warm kind man what are his
thoughts
fears hobbies favorite songs mr belding
tell our students parents and neighbors
what happened to that 500 petty cash
discrepancy discovered by the school
what don't play dumb with me where's the
cash
uh i'm sure there's an explanation it
was just a petty cash error
that's not a petty bmw you're driving
these days
i thought we were gonna talk about pokey
my pet turtle
there you have it america judge for
yourself back to you zach and lisa
let's hear strings and flute ah you're
moving me you're moving me
[Music]
[Applause]
all right movie jessie
welcome zack morris and jesse spano
[Music]
hey christy we're gonna get you that
wrestling trial before you can say hulk
hogan
what do you mean well jesse's about to
use the power of the airwaves
this is jessica spano for spano speaks
there are a lot of snorts and grunts
heard at bayside yesterday
and they weren't just from the sweaty
red-faced wrestlers
they were from the snouts of bayside's
two biggest sexist pigs coach sansky and
principal richard belding
whoa be careful way to go jesse i'd like
to present
them with the double swine award
i say if a woman wants to wrestle with
the grunts that's her business
so fellow students support women's
rights
[Music]
hey i like this
[Music]
you move pretty good thanks you're okay
too
you know we haven't fought for 15
seconds it was 20. shut up
hey um do you uh have a date for the
prom
uh no not yet how about you
i'm not exactly you know i'm still
narrowing it down
you think that uh i don't know you
perhaps
would uh slater are you asking me to go
to the prom with you
maybe you interested
maybe maybe
pick you up at seven no i'll pick you up
at seven
excuse me you're new here aren't you
welcome to bayside
no comprende senor oh you must be an
exchange student
see what's your name
huff i mean uh nombre nombre
uh maria maria tortilla
beautiful name nice to meet you hope you
like america
america see
hi mr belding exactly hi jesse
not so fast miss tortilla what is going
on jesse
what's going on golly that's a good
question uh
zack you want to answer for jesse
well sir we just finished our movie yeah
um you heard of batman well jesse played
bat
mama sita very tempting
don't even think about it
of course you're a girl so it's not like
you could hit it anyway
you know what i like about you jesse you
throw just like a girl
hey why don't you just hire a man to do
it
i hope pigs can swim
[Music]
caterpillar emerges from a cocoon
and takes a look at her new body
now she is a butterfly now she has wings
and now she can fly
[Music]
what are you talking about i had the
shop class take apart belding's
car mr sansky's a pretty cool guy he
even gave me an a
you did what they'll never get it back
together by tomorrow and that'll teach
him to mess with me
they could be expelled don't you care
about who you hurt nope
just as long as it's not me
[Music]
you are a selfish inconsiderate excuse
for a human being if i was a guy i'd
punch you out yeah too bad you're just a
chick
just a chick just a chick
i can't believe you just did that you
know i was really excited about you
coming here
i never had a brother and i thought we
could have fun be close
and do things together i tried to make
us like a real family
but you wouldn't even give it a chance
and you know what
i don't want a brother anymore
[Applause]
okay like i don't know what he said and
like i don't care
i just want to know you know are you
guys like in favor of mtv during study
hall
well then like if i'm elected we're not
gonna study we're gonna party
vote for me okay cause then we'll take
like totally rad field trips to the mall
when i'm elected like there will be hall
passes on demand
[Applause]
and now the awesome one detention will
be for teachers instead of students
oh no i've changed my mind i don't want
to go through with this anymore
my romantic future depends on what
happens here tonight besides you like
jennifer too you want to see her end up
with slater
no but come on why do i have to dress up
as the old lady
because the support holes were cutting
off my circulation now stop complaining
we got the senior discount didn't we
what do you think does it look like
they're bonding
no way they're still eating popcorn from
separate tubs
sorry sonny
gonna love this movie jen i heard mel
gibson is great in it
actually i'm getting tired of mel gibson
i like kevin costner now
kevin costner yeah he's okay
i guess what they say i can't hear them
i don't know my girl's killing me
[Music]
can i help you with something we uh you
just back up there because she i have a
nation here i'm sorry
yes you should be because there's people
like you don't make a shape for us
anymore
dude we're gonna quote wait you just
broke your bra
dork number five i gotta disagree if you
want snow white alive don't look at me
zack that's not in the script oh to make
her applause accelerate she needs a kiss
from dork
number eight it's true the prince is
just a friend but studly for me is the
living
and
[Applause]
you have miss dudley and not the prince
now that we've kissed are you convinced
uh uh well at first i didn't like
all of this drama but now i trust you so
kiss me mama
jesse hey wake up
come on we gotta go to max come on jesse
come on zach what time is it
i had to take my diy test why you
already took the test
i did yeah yeah at 6 30. come on we got
to go let's go where are we going
where are we going you're singing
tonight
singing yeah tonight can
wait what am i gonna wear jesse remember
lisa's bringing your costume
right i got to wash my hair no there's
no time no
time there's never any time i don't have
time to study
i'll never get into stanford i'll let
everyone down i'm so confused
jesse hey hey just calm down
it's okay you're right it's okay
everything will be okay
yeah i just need one of these pills
you mean you really are taking drugs i
need them jesse give me those need them
back i have to sing
just see you can't sing tonight
i'm so excited i'm so excited
i'm so scared
jesse jess jesse
hey don't be scared listen
we'll get through this hey come on
remember that time when we when we snuck
out to cet
riding home on our bikes it was so dark
and we were scared come on
you